so Hank we're gonna try something a
little different today you and I have
come up with a phrase of the week this
might not last this this bit might be
stupid but we've come up with a phrase
of the week and whoever successfully
works the phrase of the week in to our
conversation without it being obvious
that it's the phrase of the week wins
the non-existent prize of the day right
so the idea is know what like if the if
people know that I've done it before
other person you identify it
then then you win but if no one realizes
that it's happened and I don't know how
we're gonna judge that John except I
think we're gonna I think we're gonna
know in our hearts I definitely think
we're gonna know in our hearts hello and
welcome to Dear John and hey it's called
dear Hank and John a comedy podcast
about death in which me and my brother
Hank provide you with dubious advice to
answer your questions and bring you all
the week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon but first how you doing Hank
oh my god this is really distracting and
kind of feels wrong and gross I would
say that it feels just right it feels
like the podcast is always going to feel
after we don't get to Mars in 2027 how
are you I'm good John and I just want to
know everyone to know that this is
happening one time and we have 10 more
years of me doing it the normal way
before we somehow get a person to Mars I
so Hank I don't know about you but I
just experienced one of the great
wonders of the heavens it was pretty
good I also did yes and what are you
referring to because I think you might
be referring to the solar eclipse I was
correct I am referring to how it feels
when you look directly up into the sky
and rain falls into your eye
I looked directly up into the sky and a
lot of photons from the Sun fell
directly into my eye because I am that
guy who is like but if you look at it
for just a second it's okay well I don't
want to get into the talk about dubious
advice Peg's dubious advice stare
directly at the Sun
if you were a little bit it's fine it's
true
I mean it's true if you look for a
little bit it's fine and I'd also had
Eclipse glasses and I went to the office
and we had donut send everybody have a
good time looking at the Eclipse and the
thing that I was I was most surprised by
I think this is the closest I've ever
gotten to a full eclipse I was about 90%
of the Sun was occluded in missoula and
it got cold like you know went inside to
get their hoodies yeah well we had like
seven percent here in Indianapolis oh
wow um but I would say also 85 percent
cloud cover the great thing though about
our Eclipse is that I kind of enjoy
mostly cloudy eclipses because it sort
of came in and out of view and then the
moment after we were able to enjoy 97%
of the Sun not being visible it did
begin to rain huge drops directly into
my open eyes you gotta have those
glasses on John it's for preneur made a
horrible mistake Hank can we answer some
questions from our listeners
well John since you started out the
podcast I guess it's on me to do the
poem for the day oh good so I've got a
poem a short poem this is actually an
excerpt from a longer poem turn around
every now and then I get a little bit
lonely and you're never coming round
turn around every now and then I get a
little bit tired of listening to the
sound of my tears turn around every now
and then I get a little bit nervous that
the best of all the years have gone by
turn around every now and then I get a
little bit terrified and then I see the
look in your eyes turn around bright
eyes but every now and then I fall apart
turn around bright eyes every now and
then I fall apart I mean there has never
been a better time to quote the lyrics
to total eclipse of the heart but also I
would like to remind you that you cannot
again this goes for everyone quote the
lyrics to total eclipse of the heart
until the next total eclipse oh my god
states it's just Bonnie Tyler like like
what's it called
Bonnie obliged yeah so it's just like a
Bonnie Tyler black
four days for the next 2,000 days that's
exactly right Hank we got to get to some
questions from our listeners this first
one is about the sky above us it comes
from Brianna who writes Dear John and
Hank how much of the sky can I see when
I'm standing in a relatively flat part
of the earth I realized the other day
that my brain just assumed I had a
180-degree view but that can't possibly
be true I went to art school and haven't
done trigonometry in eight years can you
please help me figure this out so my
brain doesn't explode sine cosine and
tangent Brianna no sine cosine and I
like that because I thought it was gonna
say signed Brianna but it said sine
cosine a tangent okay John do you have a
good answer for this one I have it all
right you do have a good answer I have
an actual answer Oh looked at my
assumption has always been that you can
see 180 degrees of the sky like you can
see half the Earth's sky but I did
realize while reading the question that
this is not something I've thought very
hard about so give me the actual answer
well so the sitch is that the so so
we're gonna assume that you're standing
on a date like a perfectly flat spot in
the on the Earth's surface which
probably would be on a like standing on
a canoe in the middle of the ocean
so that or you could just go to Indiana
or you could just go to Indiana where
they're like just after the corn harvest
and yeah so what you're gonna see is
what it's gonna look like a 50% sky and
Earth if you look look around you but
because the earth curves away from you
and the sky does not there is actually
more sky than there is Earth and by
early you see are mostly the slide
so you're seeing most you're seeing like
more than 50% of of your like if you did
like a you know 360 degree picture with
a 360 degree camera more than 50% of the
picture would be sky
so does that mean Hank that when I look
at the sky from Indiana I am looking at
literally most of the sky you are
looking at most of the sky yes Wow
I mean probably like if you're really on
a flat spot if you like the closer you
get your head to the ground the worse it
is so if you're like on the top of a
building you can definitely see mostly
sky or most of the sky and also mostly
sky both of those things if you're on a
plane you see like 53 percent of what
you see is sky and like 47 percent is is
land or ground or however you'd call
that so but but if you're just standing
if you're like a 5 foot 6 person you're
probably see about like it's gonna be
like 50 point zero for 50 point zero
three percent of what you see is sky but
you will be and also but you will be
seeing most I will you be seeing most of
this guy I don't know if that's actually
true I don't know that you know what I
think it's but you metaphor see resonant
and so I'm just gonna stop you right
there and we are you can see most of the
sky Briana you can see in fact you can
see almost all of the sky if you're just
if you're just standing up high and
you've got you've got good posture you
can see almost all of this guy that came
directly from Hank and now we've got
another question it comes from amber who
asks dear Hank and John well the 2016
project for awesome was going on I
bought a mystery package and got an
imperial affliction
which I was super excited about so I
just started reading it and I have
noticed that the entire book except for
the very last page is the same few
paragraphs but in a different order and
I just I'm I'm just wondering if this is
a mistake I love my copy and if it's a
mistake that's totally cool but I was
just curious what actually happens in
this story so if it is a mistake could
you please tell me thank you very much
amber okay amber
I remember when I got interviewed by NPR
about this like right when the book came
out the NPR guy was like have you talked
to Peter Van Houten about you said about
him in the book and it was just before
we went on air thankfully and I was
okay well no because Peter Van Houten is
someone I made up and in an imperial
affliction is a book that does not exist
I really like books inside of books
because they can better than real books
I mean the thing about a book that
doesn't exist is that it can be
infinitely good whereas books that do
exist have all of the problems and
insufficiencies of having been created
by actual humans so when I wanted to
write about like you know that one book
that you loved or in my case there were
a couple books that I loved in high
school I decided to make the book up and
then when they were gonna make a movie
of it they called me one day the
producer people called me and they said
we need to make an imperial affliction
and we're using we're working with this
amazing graphics team who did work on
the Harry Potter stuff and they've made
a great cover here's the cover and I
thought the cover was amazing and then
they were like but we need words inside
the book that hazel can highlight so we
need you to include like these quotes
from and in The Fault in Our Stars
version of an imperial affliction but
also write at least like four or five
pages that seem legible so that's what I
did I wrote like five pages and then
they just like mixed and matched those
five pages over and over and over again
in the prop version of the book and then
Fox printed up a bunch of the prop
versions of the book for project for
awesome perks so only about I guess a
thousand of them or so exist in the
whole world and I'm glad that you have
one and I am sorry that it is not a real
novel but it is definitely not what what
you have read is is all that I will ever
write of an imperial affliction and now
now you know and so I have two questions
John first the last page is different
this is the thing I did not know I feel
like the last page is an author bio or
something I didn't write the last page
though okay second question what's your
favorite book inside a book oh that's a
great question my favorite artwork
inside of a book is the Infinite Jest in
an in Infinite Jest gosh I don't know
what's your favorite book inside of a
book I don't I was thinking my first
thought was s Morgenstern's The Princess
Bride inside of the Princess Bride but
that's not right will be how it works
I've actually I've actually broken it to
people that s Morganstern isn't real
yeah
yeah it's very believable when you I
mean the princess bread is such a great
movie but it is such a better book it is
so wonderful it is such a wonderful
reading experience but it is very it is
a very believable sort of feeling the
abridgement but you know this good old
Kilgore trout books I have right I
always go for trout place my I mean yeah
yeah I was always a big Kilgore trout
fan when I was a high school student I
loved the idea of there being these pop
science fiction books that I couldn't
read because they didn't exist but I was
reading almost in a way like Vonnegut's
fan fiction about Kilgore Trout I just
like I love that meta stuff I know that
I shouldn't and I know that it's like a
bad habit that I need to break but I
can't help but love it and I do think
that there's something about it that's
that continues to speak effectively to
our time there's another question that
we have here hanket's comes from rile
fredo who writes this is an actual email
that we received i'm going to read it in
its entirety good morning I'd like to
pre-order a copy of John Green's new
novel Turtles all the way down I'm
specifically interested in the signed
edition ISBN 978 - 0 - 5 - 5 - 5 5 5 3 8
- 4 my name is Ryan Ryan s'en and the
best email to reach me is ryan's ryan's
ryan a tri male and the best contact
number for me is i think this is the
real phone number please let me know if
you need any more information best
wishes
Ralph Ralph Fredo so just a quick
response to that that is the correct
ISBN for the signed edition of turtles
all the way down you can find out more
probably son turtles calm and the book
comes out in only 45 days Hank Wow wow
that is that that is that is very
exciting I am so glad that we don't live
in a world where you order books by
sending an email to someone hello I
would like a book I would here's the
ISBN number please send it to me here's
my address or you can call me that would
be great
well I think the best way to order a
signed copy of turtles all the way down
is in fact to call your local bookstore
but yeah it that there is something
magical about online ordering there's no
doubt about it Hank yeah in addition we
should say that in addition to our
my new book being available in in print
and online also we you and I are gonna
go we're going on tour yeah I've been
thinking a lot about what I'm gonna do
while while you have given me stage time
and it's like okay john green's book
announcement he's probably gonna read
from the book and he's Robin gonna talk
about the book and after questions about
the book and Hanks here what's he gonna
do and I'm just gonna be weird John I
get I get to make whatever I want I mean
I don't get to do whatever I want but I
pretty much do though because what I
want is stuff you want me to do and
stuff people want to see I believe that
deep in my heart yeah I mean I don't
want you to do whatever you want to do
and people don't want to see whatever
you want to do they want to see you make
something for them not something I do
okay then it's gonna be awesome I'm I am
super excited Hank and I haven't been on
tour together since 2012 I had a great
time on that to her I am really really
excited I wish we could announce what
we're going but we can't yet yeah but I
just think it's gonna be for me magical
to be able to spend time like all that
like quality time with my brother and it
is such a pleasure to see Hank perform
and it'll be fun and a little bit scary
to talk about the book we're gonna do
live versions of dear Hank and John in
every city that we visit which is gonna
be super fun we're gonna answer your
questions and provide your dubious
advice and give you all that day's news
from Mars and AFC what yes
probably not I mean it will be an
abridged version of dear Hank and John I
think sure yeah I mean which to be fair
is all anyone ever wants I mean my god
who is ever listened to this podcast
that thought is there any way it could
be longer no they actually I've heard
that feedback John I've heard that
feedback I have not mostly I've heard
can you guys say unless hey we edit out
like 90% of the arms you're getting the
best of the arms there's quality arms
the there there are uh now I'm now I'm
stuck alright let's move on this
question comes from Joel who writes Dear
John and Hank I started smoking at 13
that was dumb but I quit smoking at 15
well I mean first off Joel
congratulations because I also started
smoking at 13 and I quit smoking at like
27 and only after
six years of chewing Nicorette anyway I
quit smoking at 15 or so I thought oh
wait I got I congratulated him too early
at every party I find myself outside
with a cigarette in my hand I think it's
maybe because I like to take a break
from the party itself you know get to
step out into the cold Swedish spring or
summer or fall or winter
joel has a good sense of humor about the
miseries of living in Sweden but you
know it's nice about living in Sweden
Joel literally everything but the
weather I like to have a little time for
myself even though I'm at a party with a
bunch of people it's also a great way to
get some time with one friend but still
I want to quit smoking I'm 20 it's
starting to feel juvenile do you have
any dubious advice on how to get some
alone time at a party without a
cigarette in vino veritas Joel I just go
to the bathroom yeah oh my god I can
lock myself into the bathroom of any
party for at least 20 minutes and just
be like oh god I'm in my happy place I
really do do that I do yeah sometimes
even in my own house like you've got
people over and it is special I'm just
like I'm gonna go to the upstairs toilet
yeah where it's all mine and then like
like 10 minutes later Katherine will
text me and she's like UK up there and
I'll be like just fine baby
just time in my life there's some jokes
on Twitter you want to hear about it
exactly you won't believe you will
believe what Donald Trump did in the
last 30 minutes I just saw a really
great cat video it's uh no Joel you yeah
I mean yeah you got to quit smoking
so for four years I would go outside
with my Nicorette and I would chew a
piece of nicorette while chatting with
someone and just enjoying the smell of
their smoke just like just soaking in
that second hands I still loved
secondhand smoke like former smokers who
are like Oh secondhand smoke is the
worst I just don't understand because to
me like I am so grateful whenever
someone is doing that horrible work for
me oh no gross that's that's I know it's
dark but it was very hard for me to quit
smoking Hank as you know Joel here's
what I'll say it gets harder every day I
think that it will be harder to quit
some
tomorrow than it is today etc for the
rest of your life you're right that it's
starting to feel juvenile now is the
time now is the time just go ahead by a
pack of Swedish Nicorette I bet they
have minty flavors or better yet just
quit so you don't get addicted to
Nicorette for six years like I did and
then when you want some alone time at a
party
head to the bathroom and then other
people will start knocking and you'll be
like I'm sorry I'm not actually going to
the bathroom but I do need to take my
time in here it takes me seven minutes
to smoke a cigarette and I'm going to
spend seven minutes in here yeah or just
go outside and like look at this guy and
be like oh this is nice look at that
look at this place look at this Sweden
here look at all this great Sweden
around just go outside and like smell
the smell of like you know democracy but
still a social safety net mmm-hmm yeah
and also a king do they have a king I
think they have a king king Sweden I
googled that would be great if that was
his name his name is Karl the fourteenth
Gustaf of Sweden okay I think we're all
surprised that there's only been 16
Karl's but how is he carl xvi gustaf of
sweden what does that mean I think
Gustaf is probably his last name maybe
maybe King I'm sorry Swedish Carl Gustaf
I think his name is Carl Gustaf but he's
nobody knows for sure
did you know Hank that Carl Gustaf the
King's 16th the king's father died in
1947 in an airplane crash when Carl
Gustav was just 9 months old Oh what
there could have been a war of
succession did you know that his
grandfather who by the way was named
Gustav the 6th Adolf I don't know I have
no idea how these people came at this
point what is this weird Swedish naming
convention yeah the Crown Princess
Victoria is just named the Crown
Princess Victoria there's nothing weird
in her name oh but the we okay also
Gustav the sixth Adolf we became king
after Gustav
the fifth with a V not with an S yes
I'll tell you what they're done did they
seem to have a huge name shortage in
Sweden oh so much going right but it
seems like if you don't have really free
and open markets with lots of
competitions you end up with a huge
first name shortage uh Hank while we're
talking about Sweden mm what are you
gonna say now yeah do it
would you believe me if I told you that
Sweden has the third most medals ever in
one Summer Olympic sport and also is it
exciting it's Olympic diving isn't that
a surprise I don't know but I said it
first
God dang it first off I think they saw
it coming so I think he still might have
been the loser I think I might have
actually I think I might have
brilliantly forced your hand why making
you say Olympic diving before me even
though it was obvious where I was headed
but I was correct sweetness had 21
Olympic medals and Olympic diving behind
only China in the United States Russia
with 18 Wow I thought you made that fact
up just to wedge it in there no that's
very heavy okay I don't know this is
this isn't your number one source for
legitimate Olympic diving news well John
thank you very much for for the update
but I'm pleased to say that I won and
maybe we should have a poll on Twitter
to let people know ask people whether
they thought that I was about to drop
the word of the day or not speaking of
which before we get out of the word of
the day can I just tell you that Olympic
diving was originally known in the
Summer Olympics do you know the original
name of the sport oh no I would have
thought that it would be called diving
it was called fancy diving oh because
you know it had fanciness in it it was
it just like oh you're not just diving
into a pool you're doing somersaults
another fancy thing this is back in the
days when there was a very like kind of
low threshold for the definition of
fancy like 1904 1908 just the slightest
flourish and people would be like well
hell
somebody thinks they're special why
didn't you just wear a hat then I wonder
if you could have one like the 1908
Summer Olympic diving with just like an
amazing cannonball it's like like what
was diving the sport at a point yet
where you could blow people away we
would just like check out this full
twist yeah yeah I had that's it the
watching the evolution of of gymnastics
makes me think that like all Olympic
sports in 1908 was basically something
that anyone could today could do like
we've all drank enough milk and
everything yeah anybody could win the
100-meter dash in 1908 yeah we've just
we're all superhumans we've had all the
bovine growth hormone pumped into us the
winning time was probably like 12
minutes they didn't have food back then
they were so hungry
the air was made of coal you had a 45
percent chance of breaking your hip if
you ran a hundred meters yes it's great
to be alive today this next question
comes from Adi who asks dear Hank and
John I just picked up Chinese takeout in
my small town and when I sign my receipt
there was a tip line I didn't tip
because I was only picking up the food I
would have tipped if I was gonna sit
down to eat am I supposed to tip what
I'm gonna take out from a sit-down
restaurant wontons and egg rolls Adi
yeah I mean this is a hard one this is a
hard one and another another problem
that Sweden has solved by just not
having a real tip takeout culture I
always tip but to be fair the place that
we do take up from all of the people who
work there know who I am and talk about
me on Twitter and Facebook so it'd be
nice I feel like I that they've got me
in a corner yeah I mean I think that
that I've always thought that like a 10%
take-out tip is the thing to do that's
sort of what I do
it's sort of like half of what I would
give if I was gonna sit down
you only give 20% tips at a sit-down
restaurant I
mean that's that's that's the rule right
that's the thing now you make me think
that I'm a bad person I give a 500
percent tip no matter what but it's not
your fault that I'm better than you
no matter what if they sir if they if I
ask for fish and they serve me like just
a saucer like it's a plate with with
like cold coffee on it five hundred
percent tip thank you so much I
appreciate that I appreciate this no I
mean I think having worked as a server
made me a much better tipper I have
never had a job that made me less money
in the long run than waiting tables
because it has made me a much better
tipper although I don't take five
hundred percent but yeah Hank and I are
believers in the ten percent take out
tip but I don't think that's universal
and I don't think there's an expectation
of a tip mmm-hmm all right but this
question but but also you should not
turn to Hank and I for etiquette advice
my god I mean have you ever seen Hank
eat spaghetti
it's like watching it's like watching
Cthulhu destroy the world do you know
the best way to use spaghetti John I was
very pleased at that joke I don't know
why you didn't like it put it on like a
hoagie roll no that's disgusting and why
would you why would you carb up your
carbs yeah you got to carve up those
carbs John that's whether a hoagie roll
or spaghetti without having to eat them
together all right speaking of you being
weird John here's another question it
comes from Dean who asks dear Hank and
John so John has shield for hot tub
baths several times over the life of the
podcast as a listener who lives in a
place where bath tubs are rare and
therefore hasn't had any real experience
with them I have to ask how does one
take a bath I know that one fills the
tub with water and puts a bath bomb in
but then what is one supposed to
exfoliate when is one actually done with
a hot tub bath the few times I've had
the chance to take one I never feel much
cleaner than I did before I got in and I
always felt the urge to wash down with a
quick shower afterward I look forward to
being enlightened by
John the tub Vangelis thanks and love
there's always one who kisses and one
who offers the cheek oh my hey Dean
that's good that reminds me of a great
line by Edgar curette whose name I'm
sure I'm pronouncing ever read any of
his stories Hank no one of his stories
ends there are two kinds of people in
the world the people who sleep next to
the wall and the people who sleep next
to the people who kick them out of bed
not not no oh my we don't have a wall on
either side of our bed well I guess
you're both sleeping next to the people
who kick you that's right right ah so
let me break it down for you Dean first
off I don't want to offend my dear
sponsor lush or anything but you don't
need to use a bath balm to take an
excellent bath the key to an excellent
bath is one lighting and to the exact
right temperature in the bath itself you
also need like an appropriately sized
bathtub so that you don't feel like a
tiny child taking a bath inside of a
tiny little bathtub you need a bathtub
that is designed for a person of your
size which is surprisingly hard to find
almost as if people don't believe in
baths anymore even though for the record
they predate showers and if it was good
enough for my ancient ancestors it's
good enough for me that's my policy on
all things except antibiotics okay so
the key is the right temperature the
right lighting and then you just get in
the bath and you slowly soap up and you
rinse and you just let yourself calm
down and here's my argument Dean if you
don't have time for a bath if your life
is so rushed that you have to take a
shower where basically you're being shot
by pellets of water over and over and
over again if you don't have time to
just soak up the wonder of warm water
then why are you alive what is the point
the whole point of being alive is to
take baths I read there are lots of
people who tart half baths though John
well then they I guess you have to
construct a different meaning for life
but to me the meaning of life is bathing
oh man
that's kind of how I feel about sleep
these days I used to go to the Turkish
baths in Chicago where I where there was
a nice Turkish bath house right next to
my old apartment in Chicago and that was
great too because it was like the fun of
Bad's but with random other people well
yeah we have sort of a similar thing in
Montana because we have a lot of hot
springs so you just like sort of walk
out into the woods and then and then
you'll suddenly find a bunch of hot
pools with strangers in them in various
states of undress and you're like hey
what what's going on man
let's I'm gonna get in your tub with you
it's a nice reminder of how close heaven
is to hell you don't like the sound of
that or yeah I don't like the sound of
that I mean it depends it it depends on
the vibe you know like anything it
depends on if I feel safe and happy and
I like the vibe like anything on in life
one time I was at a hot spring and I was
in the tub the pool it was this was not
a developed hot spring it's just like
people have put rocks around the actual
spring where the hot water is coming out
so it's amazing and weird in the middle
of nowhere and I was there's some other
people in the tub with us in the pool
and then a moose appeared and it was
super idyllic and there were these
people and everyone was wearing clothes
so it wasn't awkward in the way that
sometimes it makes me feel awkward
though you do it your way no big deal
and so we're like watching this moose
and he's like eating this grass that's
been you know like lush and lake watered
by the hot springs and the the guy who's
in the tub with me he says moose hooves
like razors and that was and that was
suddenly I had a very different feeling
about the entire situation so Katherine
and I often will say hooves like razors
whatever we see
an animal that we don't that we don't
want to get too close to oh man you know
what that makes me think of Hank mmm it
makes me think that during the 1904
Olympics you were not allowed to do a
dumber double somersault because it was
considered dangerous too fancy no it's
too fancy I just have to do one
somersault if one somersault was good
enough for our ancestors it's good
enough for the people of 1904 they said
this podcast is brought to you by fancy
diving it's fancy but not too fancy
no never you don't want to go over the
top with your fanciness when it comes to
diving today's podcast has also brought
to you by Bonnie Tyler Bonnie Tyler
performing total eclipse at the heart
for the last time until 2027 as podcast
has additionally brought to you by
Swedish Nicorette Swedish Nicorette
don't probably find another way to quit
because then you'll just be addicted to
Swedish Nicorette and lastly we do have
an actual sponsor for today so Hank I
have a nice story about today's sponsor
as you know when my book The Fault in
Our Stars was published they made an
audiobook from it which was narrated by
Kate Rudd you've met Kate she went to
nerdcon stories lovely person also an
incredibly good audiobook narrator like
the kind of narrator where you realize
oh wow this is an art and people are
sometimes good at it and sometimes
terrible at it anyway
Kate is amazing and I'm so happy to be
able to announce today that Kate will be
doing the narrating the audiobook for
Turtles all the way down as well which
also has a female narrator and Kate and
I just had a conversation about the book
and it was really cool to be able to
talk to her about it and here you know
some of the voices that she's gonna be
doing for the characters and everything
and I'm just really excited and
audiobooks are a completely different
kind of art in a lot of ways I think
then then print books but really
important and an interesting way to get
your stories which brings us to today's
sponsor which is audible you can get a
free audiobook with the 30-day trial of
audible over at audible.com slash dear
John dear Hank that can include up right
or dear Hank and that can include
Turtles all the way down the audio for
Turtles all the way down uh yeah can you
pre-order it already I think you can
yeah it comes out the same day as the
regular book yes so John I had I had an
interesting speaking of audiobook
narrators had an interesting audiobook
experience recently where I listened to
the hate you give which was narrated by
Bonnie Turpin and then immediately
afterward probably like no one else on
earth got this book called born Bo R and
E which is like a post apocalypse
biotech story it that is narrated by
Bonnie Turpin and that was a weird
experience because it was the same
person narrating oh well very very
different stories Rob and it took me a
little while to make the shift but I did
it without without doing an in-between
ebook because I was enjoying born so
much it's really cool and weird and I'm
like two hours from the end of it and
I'm basically that's what I want to be
doing right now John III do it with you
but I really want to know how this book
ends and how was a how great how great
was the hate you give oh it was that was
a book that I could not listen to the
way I normally listen to audiobooks
because it's so beautiful and intense
and hard and and sad and but wonderful
ya know it's a really it's a really
special book one of the best young adult
books I've ever read and I'm so excited
that it's reaching such a broad audience
anyway you can get all of these books
through audible over at audible.com
slash Dear John or audible.com slash
dear Hank I know you hear about it on
every podcast but use our link though it
really is great it's an it's an amazing
service and and you don't know how much
audiobooks will enhance your life until
you start listening to them and then
you'll probably stop listening to our
podcast so that's kind of a bummer for
but we want what's best for you in the
long run that's right and also what's
best for all the great authors of
America so have more people interfacing
with their work including Turtles all
the way down read by Kate Rudd whoo yeah
this next question asked dear Hank and
John my boyfriend and I had an argument
about whether humans are radioactive he
says that everybody probably has one
radioactive atom in them I say that is
because a cake has salted it doesn't
make it salty then we looked up the
definition of salty and it said that
anything it said that it was anything
that contains salt which is more
important definition or connotation is
cake salty sienta at AXA tatum jenkin
Hanh apparently that's the name of this
person
jenkin huh hmm it's a suspicious name
cake is not salty okay and the idea that
any humans are not radioactive anything
that contains salt is not salty that is
not what salty means that that is nor in
fact is that actually what the
dictionary says the definition of salty
is I'm looking at the definition of
salty right now and it says tasting of
containing or preserved with salt now I
guess you could argue that anything
containing salt is salty according to
but I think it's mostly tasting of or
preserved with that's what defines
saltiness I'm really interested in and
in the use graph over time of the word
salty which got pretty peaked around
1950 and then lulled off for a little
bit and now has shot right back up so I
think it's because we used to have like
you know people would be like oh well
he's a salty dog uh-huh and now maybe
people are starting to say that again
sensing like course humor yeah should I
am I a salty dog Chad no oh
hmm no should I be no no I I quite like
you just the way you are please don't
change and start using a bunch of 1950s
hip slang it'll be so cringy oh boy this
podcast is boffo oh god it's starting I
knew that it was gonna happen I knew
there was no way if you had asked this
question that you weren't going to start
saying boffo largely googling 1950s
slang trying to think of you want a guy
to me you can use to go
50 slang so the thing that I wanted to
say is that like like I feel like there
there are different there are things
like salty which is how you experience
it and then radioactive which is it's
just a property of a thing so like
containing salt means that there's salt
in it and radioactive means that there
is some radioactive decay going on so
there like it is emitting particles and
we are radioactive we have potassium and
potassium has you know a radioactive
isotope and and it's inside you and you
emit particles and that's like that
that's a whole that's the whole thing of
degrees like you could have something
that is very safe and and radioactive
and something that is very dangerous and
also radioactive and so that you need
more than just that one word to describe
how dangerous something is and I think
that we often not just in this word but
in lots of words get caught up in the
idea that if that if you are any amount
of one thing that you are that thing and
that is a failing of language oh that's
a great point and really a surprisingly
artful point from that question since
you came close to talking about politics
and can I ask one political question
sure this question comes from Samantha
who writes Dear John and Hank I've been
a nerdfighter for six or seven years now
but I've recently become more
politically conservative and have
greater understanding of politics in my
belief and I'm struggling with hearing
people in communities like my tumblr
friends and in my field of work and
study I work in graphic design
expressing views about evil Republicans
in front of me and being afraid to
explain my own thoughts on a topic
because I would be an evil Republican
and their eyes this happens a lot around
issues like welfare where I'm against
government welfare because I don't
believe it's the best way to help
struggling and impoverished Americans
not because I don't believe in helping
people how do I talk about my political
views without being labeled evil and
racist and homophobic and Islamophobic
because my views want me in with a lot
of other people that do fit those terms
is it worth speaking up at all anxieties
and blueberries Samantha mmm I don't
know John you answer that question
because you're the one that wanted to
ask it well I mean here's the thing I I
think that anytime people are talking to
what
they believe to be themselves or
preaching to what they believe to be the
choir they talk differently than when
they're talking to like trying to talk
to a broader public and I think that's I
think that's like a failure of discourse
right now that we aren't doing a good
job of doing much other than preaching
to the choir and and kind and it's
converting the converted yeah and we
like it we like doing it it's
comfortable and it feels good and it's
like you know it's easy it's the easy
thing to do and then if you you know
like that there's that buy concern that
like Oh is my opinion in this room
making everyone have less of a good time
because well yeah I mean there's that
but I also think actually in Samantha's
question is a little bit or one solution
at least to Samantha's problem which is
that she writes this happens around
issues like welfare uh because I don't
believe it's the best way to help
struggling and impoverished Americans so
let's have a conversation about about
policy Samantha instead of about ideas
like welfare so when we talk about
welfare what are we talking about are we
talking about unemployment insurance are
we talking about you know that which is
something that people pay into while
they have work and then if you lose your
job you receive unemployment benefits
for a certain amount of time as long as
you're still looking for work does that
constitute welfare or is that separate
from your definition of welfare what
about Social Security disability
benefits which go to people with
disabilities who are unable to work
because of they have a physical or
intellectual disability that prevents
them from being able to work is that
welfare and if so you know it's not
really a matter of incentivizing people
to work in that case because most of
those people can't participate in the
workforce
what about low at the low-income heating
provision that's part of the federal
government's benefits where people who
live in apartments or houses who can't
afford their heating bills in the winter
get assistance from the federal
government if we talk specifically about
programs that are part
the current federal government and what
we would like to see instead or what we
think the world should look like instead
of the way that it looks like now
instead of vague kind of ideologically
driven ideas like the word welfare I
think we get a lot closer to being able
to have a real conversation rather than
just kind of staking out ideological
ground and then sort of throwing rocks
at each other mm-hmm yeah and I like
John perfectly honest like I I until you
said all those things didn't like
couldn't have even articulated a well
for a program like what single one well
we'd actually don't have yeah we don't
have a ton of welfare programs in the
United States I mean we spend a lot of
money on Social Security but most of it
is is for people who are retired and
have paid into the Social Security
system for most of their working lives
and then we spend a ton of money on
providing health care to people through
Medicare which is for elderly people in
Medicaid which is for certain people who
live in poverty not everyone who lives
in poverty but certain people who live
at or near the poverty line can get
health care through Medicaid especially
kids and both all of that which are the
central sort of like welfare or
redistribution payments in the u.s.
right now are really popular with both
Republicans and Democrats and so I
actually think if we talked in specifics
instead of in kind of ideologically
charged language we would find a lot
more overlap yeah yeah I agree I agree
this next question comes from Seamus who
asks dear Hank and John I learned that
in the upcoming reboot of DuckTales
saying Huey Dewey and Louie also now
refers to their birth order how do you
determine the birth order of an animal
that hatches from an egg is it which egg
comes out first or which egg hatches
first also can you have identical twin
birds that we might not solve a mystery
or rewrite history Seamus I've watched
the first episode of the new duck tales
Hank yeah it made me extremely nostalgic
for the old duck tales why would you
change something that's already perfect
why do we need older
and younger brothers when we already had
the perfect television program well was
where he we doing Louise do they used to
be triplets or something it was never
considered it because it doesn't matter
we don't need sibling rivalry in the
ducktales universe it's just not
necessary
oh as their sibling rivalry I haven't
watched yet I'm very excited to see it
as this star-studded cast but I have not
it's very good it's very good
I just wanted me because all I want of
course is for it to be like the old duck
tales I am a simple person on one fancy
diving to contain no more than one
summer salt baths for everyone forever
no matter what and the regular old duck
tales I don't even want baths so so as
for as for birth order I don't know I
think probably it's which egg hatches
first but also like there could be two
eggs hatching simultaneously so it like
is it when the little egg tooth first
pops out or is that when the chick first
gets like like out of the egg completely
I don't know that seems complicated to
me but I do have an answer to can you
have identical twin birds because Jon do
you know how this happens I have I mean
absolutely not
so when you have a bird and you have to
like if you have identical it's like in
a person you have identical twin if
they're both hanging out there in the in
the uterus together in a bird they hang
out in the egg together oh wow so when
you have identical or fraternal twins
there are two birds that grow inside the
same egg and so the vast majority of
times those birds do not live because
that's a cramp to space to be a bird but
it does happen
there was a study they so they looked at
200 eggs that contain two embryos
whether that was a double yolk egg which
would be fraternal twins or whether the
yolk split early on and that would be
identical twins and found that only one
of the eggs produced two happy healthy
babies so it does happen but it does not
happen very often because it means it's
biologically constrained
there hmm so you can tickle twin birds
and I was very surprised and interested
to find that out thank you for asking
the question Seamus because I did not
know I am also surprised it was weird
how you put on your best Agatha Christie
voice at the end of it but that little
bit there but I liked it that's my new
thing John when I'm discovering new
facts about the universe haha boy man
okay I mean I'm very close to mentioning
something from your past that I've never
mentioned and I'm like Icarus flying
toward the Sun and I want to just I want
to say it but I'm not going to out of
respect for you thank you thank you John
for for leaving off no one is no one
should ever know no one really it's the
rare thing that is just it's too much
but this question comes from Emma writes
do John and Hank this weekend I'm going
on a date with a lovely girl and I can't
contain my excitement Oh however this
upcoming date has made me wonder at what
point can I say that we are officially
dating well not before your first date
that's for sure obviously now would be
far too soon I wouldn't say far too soon
but when could i appropriately tell
people that I am dating someone three
dates ten dates is it after a certain
amount of time like a month please
answer swiftly as I'm in desperate need
to reveal our probable love to the world
Wow Wow is this a rebound oh you're
excited a montes into montes Emma I
assume that means I am really in love
with this person that I'm going out on a
date with the first time in a couple in
a couple weeks yes the latin for a
clingy clingy clingy thing I don't know
I don't know exactly what that means
sake but I assume it means I am really
excited about yeah yeah John yeah I
haven't dated anyone in so many years
why don't we ever take this okay I think
that you can say that you're dating when
it's obvious to you that you are dating
I have a conversation
if you want there's a few strategies
here you can have the conversation but I
would not recommend the first date no
for that conversation I would recommend
like after the third date for that
conversation at the earliest yeah
assuming weekly dates I think I got that
if there is an assumption that you're
gonna go out on another date and you
don't really have to ask thing it right
yes it's when it becomes of course
there's no more asking it's just like
what are we doing this weekend
yeah that's dating I think but like Hank
it has been some time since I have
dipped my toes into those waters and I
must say I am not nostalgic for them no
no no it means lovers are crazy by the
way oh yeah all right it's cute it's
cute good luck Emma we wish you well and
since you asked that question six months
ago probably you're now married I hope
everything has gone well John let's do
one last question before we get to the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon this
one comes from Haley who asks dear Hank
and John longtime listener first-time
Potter that's not what it says but
whatever I have a question of a
neighborhood etiquette if my dog poops
during a long walk and I secure it in a
plastic bag am I allowed to throw it
away and somebody else's garbage on the
side of the road cuz I hate bein rude
but I also hate carry and poop feces and
fiestas Haley I mean this is why I don't
walk my dog just so I'm not presented
with these kind of difficult problems I
do I do that I did I did that I would
always pick up the lemon poop but I
would occasionally drop it in somebody
else's trash
I just feel yeah I swing this bag of
poop all the way home if I'm like I know
but then there's potentially saying to
somebody like if you clean the poop out
of your garbage bag witnesses if luckily
theoretically it's the garbageman who
cleaned the poop out of the ballade do
the thing and they're gonna do it at my
house they're gonna do it at their house
as long as I like
I it seems very marginal to me this is
why everyone on several acres of land
and Willie is allowed to roam free yeah
I do have this this Fiat like I don't
like if there's a person standing on the
porch I'm not gonna do it so like I know
that there's something wrong with that
exactly yeah and go bingo bingo bingo
Hank before we get to the news from Mars
and AFC Wimbledon I need to read one
correction which time to John mostly but
also Hank
sure Trisha writes I'd like to write
with the correction on the 102nd episode
of the pod John reported that only one
model three was delivered in July of
this year is a Tesla thing my husband
works for Tesla and every time I see a
Tesla I inform whoever is nearest hey my
husband made that with his bare hands it
drives him crazy but I'm very proud of
him in the work he does it will also
drive him crazy that I took the time to
write this correction but he's not the
boss of me 30 model threes were
delivered in July of 27 in full
production on the cars is well underway
as I write this now it was still several
years past the Elon time line of course
but you can't imagine what kind of
overtime and struggle the workers
endured to get not just one but 30 Model
3 cars out that's okay
I think a 29 car difference is
significant enough to write in and I
hope you'll give them a shout out Trisha
Trisha thank you to your husband for
making such high-quality electric
vehicles and I'm sorry good job John
what's the news room AFC Wimbledon Hank
have you ever witnessed a complete solar
eclipse no have you ever witnessed a
near complete solar eclipse yes so what
you will no doubt remember is that a
darkness fell over the land and it
became cold and barren
not really the bird stopped singing in
midair
and fell to the ground the goats fainted
the gods themselves knelt down and
begged reprieved a man who is in the
middle of his double fancied sub result
dive just stopped and he did it in
midair as the cold descended yeah and
and darkness washed across the land and
the crops died and etc anyway that that
was better and more fun than AFC
Wimbledon's League One season so far
Oh Hank it's very very worrisome it's a
very worrisome situation you still got
that just that one goal under your belt
we still have just scored the one goal
this season on the heels of not scoring
a goal in the last like six games of
last season I remember and we've we've
we've had the 1-1 draw against
Scunthorpe and we lost one nil to
Shrewsbury and now we've lost two nil to
Fleetwood I mean I want to like find a
silver lining in this this goal scoring
drought and this plummeting down the
table the good news is that while while
AFC Wimbledon are in the relegation
spots right now they are only two points
away from being in like 15th place
because that's very early in the season
right so things have to get worked out
things have to get figured out yeah I'm
definitely nervous but I also it's a
long season and it was never going to be
easy the second season in a new league
is always hard in the first season so
it's I got butch abhava
we did have a new signing we signed
somebody from Rangers which is a team in
Scotland ah yeah I mean he's a winger
and we need some offense so that's good
I guess his name's Harry Forester he is
known as in in Scotland I don't want to
speak ill of him on the world's second
leading AFC Wimbledon podcast but in
Scotland he was known as something of a
troublemaker
but to be fair Neil art Lee has turned
around people with bad reputations in
the past
so hopefully Harry Forester is going to
score four hundred and sixty-two goals
over the next thirty eight weeks and AFC
Wimbledon will rise right to the
championship time will tell
good luck and I'm glad to hear that
you've at least you're at least moving
on players and not just sort of sticking
with the current squad ya know it's uh
well we'll see life is long and we'll
see we'll see
John so question who owns Mars oh I know
the answer to that America well more
broadly than that there's a conversation
going on around who owns the stuff that
is mined in outer space because people
are looking at the future of mining
stuff in outer space and mostly this
would be useful for use in outer space
so it's the first thought is like hey if
we found a bunch of gold in space we
could bring it back to earth and then
there would be gold and you could sell
it on earth but really what we like it's
expensive to move stuff around in space
to get it from space to earth to get
earth stuff to space so what we're
mostly looking at is taking stuff that's
in space and building things with it or
using it as fuel to move stuff that's
already in space around so you don't
have to launch all your water up into
space I have to watch once all your
hydrogen your oxygen up into space you
can go to space mine the water and then
use it now there are starting to be
enough people looking to do this that
governments want to avoid conflicts
between companies and countries over
resources out in space and are starting
to have some rules and the u.s. is
looking at a rule that says if you can
grab it and take it with you then it
becomes your property oh okay well I
mean to be fair that is sort of the
approach that the US has taken to land
management over the last couple
centuries so seems reasonable it's not a
huge change in policy so if you obtain
the
resource and bring it with you it
becomes your property so it's not your
property while it's on the ground but as
soon as you pick it up and bring it with
you it becomes yours so it's like fine
now if you put it back down it's not
yours anymore but if you pick it back up
it's yours they put it down it's not
yours which is I guess the rule that we
have for most rocks like Raja and unless
I'm holding onto it and I put it back
down it's not my rock anymore
yeah that's not strictly speaking it's a
little bit of an oversimplification of
u.s. land management but only a little
bit I mean I feel like if I go to a
river and I pick up a rock that's my
rock now if I take it back to my house
put it in my house and you steal that
rock you stole my rock but if I put it
back down on the on the riverbank
that's not my rock right I don't know
man this is how ownership works but I
quit but I couldn't like take a
bulldozer and like scoop up a thousand
rocks and bring those with me people be
like you can't just take those rocks but
I would take one rock I feel like it's
okay but it's probably not it's probably
illegal I probably shouldn't take those
rocks but I'm going to any no yeah yeah
just erm just four more but not a lot of
them just a bunch a few from from areas
where people don't usually take Rock so
it's just me yeah yeah I mean I do you
wanna I feel like this is complicated
interstellar law that we're not really
ready for yet and we're gonna have to do
it the same way we did it the last time
which was just horrific alee hopefully
there's no there's not people to steal
from out there except for each other
right but don't worry we will find a way
to do it
inequitably I know it I believe in us
100% human beings we amaze me i I
continue I continue to be astonished by
all the things that humans need to make
laws for because of all the weird new
stuff we keep doing it's sort of
inspirational but also sort of
horrifying like the internet and most
other things well I should say that
there is also some some outerspace
law confusion and so other people are
not quite so sure that it is as simple
as I just said but
rules in space good luck enforcing them
there's no space cops yep that's all
yeah yeah I mean there you go there's no
space cops it's gonna be hard in space
without space cops man how is there a
great space cop science fiction novel
link because I love detective fiction I
love like hard-boiled cops but I don't
know if it's my job yes yes yes
Leviathan wakes Leviathan wakes by James
sa Corey the expanse series there's like
seven of them but Leviathan wakes is is
the one that is from the perspective of
like literally undo our detective who
lives in the a that sounds good it's so
good all right well I will go check that
out on audible okay yeah I thought I did
I in fact listened to it it was good
well now I'm excited up I'm gonna check
it out Hank do you remember when my this
Machine Kills Fascists ticker that is on
my laptop and is on in all the crash
course videos when it was not a
politically charged statement yeah I do
remember that Oh God okay with that
noted thanks to everybody for listening
um you can set these questions at Hank
and John at gmail.com or find us on
Twitter I'm John Green Hank is Hank
green and we really appreciate you
listening and let us know if you like
this stupid noob it with the phrase of
the week I liked it I like that I think
you did it I think you came up with a
good thing John I want to do better next
week I'm already looking forward to it
this podcast is edited by Nicholas
Jenkins it is produced by rosianna halse
rojas and sheridan Gibson our social
media manager is Victoria Bongiorno the
music is by the great gunnarolla our
podcast sponsor is audible audible.com
slash dear Hank and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]